but first we're joined by the health
Secretary Mike Hancock thank you very
much for being with us said this morning
bright and early a conference great to
be here
you've got announcement today haven't
you what is it that you're planning to
do well we're going to start the largest
hospital building program in in a
generation and we've announced that
we're going to be rebuilding 40
hospitals right across the country and
of course recruiting the people who are
going to work in them we we care deeply
about making sure that the NHS is there
for you and for your family and it's
sustainable into the long-term and so
we're putting 13 billion pounds extra
additional money into this plan we can
find the money it's not going through
PFI or any of those sorts of schemes
that have been used in the past we can
find the money because the economy is
strong and this means that we can
rebuild our NHS so you know if you're in
one of those hospitals and in Harlow and
whips cross in London for instance where
you know the doctors find it hard to get
around the patient could CETIS because
the building's too small or where the
roofs leaking and dripping then we're
going to rebuild those hospitals and the
six that will start straightaway the
rest will get the we will start the
development work right now and so I want
to get into some of the specifics of
this announcement you saying that
there's six hospitals that you're going
to start straightaway that you've
already in like that money from the
Treasury for so these new hospitals or
they just rebuilding hospitals that
already there yes in many cases there
are rebuilding hospitals that have been
crumbling essentially you know take
whips cross which the Prime Minister
visited a couple of weeks ago that
hospital is is is is almost a hundred
years old it's totally inappropriate for
modern care well I understood his
frustration now asked as did the PM and
it was here we couldn't say at the time
but we're going to rebuild this hospital
and also employ the extra people who are
needed in in to run the services so is
it new money and where's it coming from
so all this is new additional money to
the NHS budget it's coming from the
Treasury it's intimately Brostrom it
comes from taxpayers and
reason that does it come from increase
borrowing this oh no it comes because
we've got record numbers of people in
work so we've got more people paying
income tax so the tax revenues are
coming in so it's coming because the
economy's strong it's one of the things
about good public services you can only
fund them with the strong economy and
okay so these are the six initial ones
yes they're their immediate their plans
are already ready and they have got the
go-ahead to get that building going you
always say say you want another 34
hospitals and you promised 100 million
pounds yes now I'm not an economist but
I don't think that's enough is it that
they'll see don't fall so where's the
rest of the money coming from so the
rest of the money will come in the
future what's happening well that will
also come from our taxpayers but it'll
come in government the government we
came into the future yes we'll work out
how to yes come up with these extra
billions yes that's exactly right
and let me be a little bit more honest
to say look we've got six hospitals that
we're building we would committed this
money
I mean 34 schools in the future paid for
each other I'll tell you let me explain
because this is an incredibly important
point that you raise in the pass of the
last generation hospitals have been
largely built using PFI this was a
really bad way of building hospitals
because then the hospitals are hamstrung
with the PFI debts for years to come and
also constraints on how you can use the
hospital you know if you want to change
anything you have to go and find the PFI
lenders and they and the company and ask
them instead we're building these
hospitals on the government balance
sheet using taxpayers money but you
cannot say how thirty four the forty
will be funded I mean no I can I was
coming on to that so instead of having
this sort of piecemeal approach where
whoever can get a PFI contract can then
build a new hospital we're going to have
a strategic approach to replacing
hospitals over the years ahead we're
going to have what's called a health
infrastructure plan and in the first
five years of this plan we're getting on
with the projects the six projects I
outlined but we're also giving the seed
funding now for the next
yes away exactly 4:30 for hospital yes
for the for the planning the design work
the business case development so that
the next set of hospitals that need to
be rebuilt can be ready to have that
investment over this decade so it so
will it lose private investment no no no
all pairs money yes I'm still really
confused as to where this money is
straightforward it's really straight
talking about strategic plans yes seed
funding and you can't tell me why the
money's coming for me pressure hasn't
given it to you the Treasury is
committed to supporting these projects
we have to disarm tools now know the
government is giving the go-ahead to the
all 40 and we're giving the the the
money immediately to the first six and
for the the following 34 we're having a
strategic pipeline so that we that mean
let me it's let me I'm explaining but
you keep interrupting this and that
makes it harder to explain it means that
we're giving the funding now to get the
project ready
so that we can get it built in the years
ahead
you can't build hospitals just by saying
we're clicking your fingers and saying
we're going to rebuild that one okay
there are hospitals around the country
take Derriford in Plymouth the hospital
I know well I've done a night shift
there brilliant
local MP Johnny Mercer that hospital is
clearly coming towards the end of its
life and it has problems in terms of the
physical infrastructure but they haven't
got a plan that if I said here's here's
the money several hundred million pounds
for them to immediately get going and
rebuild it they need the architects they
need the design work they need the
planning they need to make sure they've
done the business case so the money's
spent wisely I'm giving them the seed
funding now to do that work so that so
that over the next decade they can
rebuild they don't need the new hospital
immediately but they need to know that
it's coming that's why I described it as
a strategic approach instead of you know
a piecemeal who's ready to build a
hospital I'm saying
we'll get going immediately on the first
six under and then we'll have a pipeline
all of the rest over the decade to come
as a nation we're getting fat on is it
time to extend the sugar tax well the
evidence on the sugar tax is incredibly
powerful and it shows that there's a
very significant reduction in the amount
of sugar that people drink it's working
it's successful we've said that we will
have a formal review next year we said
when we announced the sugar tax a few
years ago that we would review it in
2020 so earlier this month we published
well public health England published
information published evidence on how
it's working you know it's it's
brilliant that the amount of sugar in
sugary drinks has fallen by 1/4 since
the sugar tax was brought in I think
that's absolutely terrific and and I'm
glad that it's it's working so would you
like it rolled out further because what
it also shows is that while like you say
the sugar and sugary drinks is going
down manufacturers aren't doing the same
are they on other products that haven't
been taxed so would you like to sit
extended to other unhealthy sugary
products well this is a question that
we're going to address in a year's time
what's your gut feeling well my I think
it's good idea my gut feeling is that
it's working ok thank you and now I just
want to go through talking a little bit
more widely away from your brief about
some of other things because of course
you know we've soft-spoken
when you were running for leader
yourself a lot has changed since then
and I just really look back at some of
the things that you said when you were
pitching for the top job yourself
so in June and when you were running to
be Prime Minister you said no deal is
not a policy option available to the
next prime minister the real choice is
between leading with a deal or no breaks
them is that your view well I think that
I've said before that I think that that
I was surprised after saying that by the
Parliament not voting in the summer to
prevent No Deal but clearly Parliament
has made its view clear in the Ben Act
that was passed at the start of this
sort of this month and I think that the
best way to leave is with a deal
absolutely I've always thought that but
we've got to get brexit done so that we
can get on to
on all the other things like the NHS
which I'm responsible for like on
schools and extra 20,000 so I assure you
then that I can tell that you think
leaving with a deal is the best option
but what's the choice is it between
leaving without a deal and not living at
all well we've got always no deal do you
think realistically on the table we've
got to get breaks it done I think yeah
absolutely no deal and may well happen
so you change your mind then yes I have
and I said that a few weeks ago I
absolutely think we have got to get
breaks it done
I made that that's the other argument I
was making when I was running we've got
to get breaks it down so that you can
then get on to all of the other things
you know the public is deeply frustrated
with all these rounds about practicing
all the noise in politics at the moment
and and and all of the all of the
language let's get brexit done because
then we can get on to things like the
NHS which unites people rather than
divide them you mentioned the Ben atlas
of course there's the move by MPs to try
and compel the prime minister to extend
if you can't get a deal rather than
leave with no deal do you think there's
loopholes on that or do you think the
Prime Minister will have to obey the Ben
act if you can't go to do well then
clearly the prime minister in the
government will obey the law
but we've got to also we've got to get
brexit done and what does that mean for
an extension if you can't get a deal the
best way through all of this Sophie is
to get a deal that's why I should be
that's what we are working towards well
we've still got to get breaks it done as
a country right there are people out
there who say let's have a second
referendum but that doesn't solve brexit
at all that would just prolong the Rao
for for even longer and there's people
who say now people who just say we'll
just revoke well that wouldn't solve
this political route brexit in this
country at all we're a democracy and in
a democracy when the people vote whether
you agreed with them or not you follow
the result and they voted to leave and
so people like me who voted remain in
that referendum we should listen to the
result we should act on the result and
let's get this done and then we can move
for
you talk about living in a democracy and
we're a parliamentary democracy of
course and during that campaign you also
said to suspend Parliament explicitly to
pursue a course of action against its
wishes it's not a serious policy of a
prime minister in the 21st century it
undermines parliamentary democracy it
goes against everything that those men
who waded onto these beaches fought and
died for I mean I'm not dredging up
quotes from the distant part all right
this is pink shoes this proposal at the
time was just it was a per robe suspend
Parliament all the way through to the
1st of November and against you instead
we pirates sat for the first two weeks
in September it passed a law during that
time so Parliament has been able to
express its view it's sitting it's
sitting next week even whilst
Conservative Party conference the
Supreme Court ordered it to come back
the back end of last week and it'll be
there this week last week it's sat for
two days after the Supreme Court quashed
the progressional decision we didn't we
only had one vote on one thing which was
whether to have a recess this week there
was there was no there were no votes on
substantive issues and there's a reason
for that and that is that the moment to
get a deal to deliver brexit with a deal
is the European Council on the 17th of
October until then we don't have a new
proposal to have a vote on in Parliament
hundreds and hundreds of hours let's
talk about let's talk about some of the
things that Parliament did talk about
and in that time when it was recalled
because there was some very passionate
debate about abuse but mp's feeling
worried for their safety and poor
Sheriff Labour MP said we stand here
under the shield of our departed friend
Joe Cox many of us in this place are
subject to death threats and abuse every
single day let me tell the Prime
Minister they often quote his words the
Prime Minister replied humbug is it
humbug well you're actually only partly
quoting it so it's a bit unreasonable so
should I have put in well you should
have the [ __ ] the final sentence
so let me tell the Prime Minister that
they were also quite as words surrender
up to betrayal traitor it's not that you
mean yes because the look I think is
totally reasonable to call the the been
act a surrender act the surrender act
right and that's because that literally
done by is it humbug well the very
dismissive isn't it
the Prime Minister that was referring to
calling the been act the surrender act
he thinks that's perfectly reasonable I
think it's perfectly reasonable and and
that is the and that's the debate that
was that was going on in the comments at
the time I wasn't actually there for
that exchange but the it is reasonable
to call this act that makes it so much
harder for the Prime Minister negotiator
stand the the what you're saying
defending those words there is a wider
of concern isn't there I mean Joe
Swenson has had to report threats to
have children to the police it's weak
just Phillips has seen someone trying to
smash a window in her office yet
Cooper's daughter has come out saying
that she's scared every single day
because they have an explosive Bank to
catch the mail at their family home and
the Prime Minister stands and says
humbug he wasn't he was referring to
something else and you don't somehow two
opinion no I'm not because it's
incredibly important that we have a high
quality public discourse I care deeply
about that I've always tried personally
as a in public life to use reasonable
language and to make the argument rather
than just use the rhetoric that's I mean
all of us get overexcited from time to
time but that has always been my
approach and yeah I think you'd agree
with that the the challenge is how do
you make sure that on all sides some of
this aggressive language is de-escalated
you know as in a way as conservatives we
have you grow up with having this sort
of language thrown at you from the other
side and and that doesn't excuse it on
any side by the way but you know when
you have some of the stuff that John
McDonald said in particular and I single
him out because he is the he's the
address I don't want to get into an odd
one here
is worse I just think it's a bit of a
race to the bottom no you just let me
finish because that is exactly the point
that I wanted to make right is that I
think it's incumbent on all sides
it's incoming on all sides but what I'm
but it is frustrating to hear some of
the accusations obviously from the other
side but it's incumbent on everybody to
have positive language I'm trying to
hurry a little bit because I know we
have a limited time in the in the
interview and just very quickly an Amber
rod said in an interview this week
talking about the language that we're
coming coming up number 10
does incite violence she urged ministers
to consider their own judgments rather
than be desperately loyal
are you considering growing judgments or
you desperate yeah my judgement is that
we absolutely should use language that
tries to bring people together and we
should concentrate on the things that
really matter to be broken this is why
we should get brexit done so we can get
on to the things that bring the country
together like the NHS one more question
while we've got you and the prime
minister's been referred to the police
watchdog for allegations in his time as
London they're regarding a businesswoman
called Jennifer our Curie are you
concerned does he have questions to
answer hit no my understanding is that
there's a that there's a investigation
all of the money's any money's involved
I went through proper due process and
this was from a long time ago I think
actually the message that you're gonna
get out of this conference is one of
that's forward-looking that's positive
it's about the hope that we can bring
once we can get breaks it done you know
and the delivering 40 new hospitals that
that that I'm announcing today is an
example of this you know we are here to
deliver on the priorities that people
care about and the NHS education police
getting brexit done so we can get onto
all of these subjects that's what
matters to people and and of course in
politics there's always schools and
there's always there's always debates
about individual storynest what really
needs to what really matters is that we
deliver for people so the hospital
better so there's enough people to trick
them when they're ill and to make sure
they have the education police services
that they need that's really for me what
politics is all about okay Health
Secretary Mike Hancock thank you very
much being on the program today